CAMPBELL: I'm Ken Campbell.
I'm the director
of the News Office.
And today's session has become
an embargoed private briefing
for the night Science
Journalism Fellows
at MIT the embargo is for
11 AM Eastern Daylight
Time on Tuesday, May 2, which
means that it should not
appear in any publication-- any
place in the world before then.
And we've been getting great
cooperation from the press
to adhere to this embargo.
We've used this embargo because
this is a very complex story,
and it's not one
that you can just
whip off in a half an hour.
So you need to have
some time to look at it,
and study it, and
then write a more
comprehensive story
than is ordinarily
available under deadline.
So I'd like to turn
the proceedings over
to Michael Dertouzos, the
Chairman of the Commission,
and first, Paul Gray,
the President of MIT,
will speak and introduce
Professor Dertouzos.
GRAY: Good morning, and
thank you for coming.
We're here today because
we have an urgent message
to convey to America
to its financial
and industrial community, and
to the millions of Americans who
rely on industry for
their livelihoods.
The message is that
American productivity
is slipping, even though the
United States is still the most
productive nation in the world.
The weaknesses in
American industry
concern the way people think,
cooperate, invest, manage
and organize
themselves, as well as
the ways they become
educated, use technology,
learn a new job, and
interact with government.
We need to rethink the
way we do business,
and the way we
live in the world.
International
industry is driving
along a highway of many lanes.
The US is ahead right now, but
we're driving in the slow lane.
Other nations are
speeding along behind us,
and some are about to zoom past.
Why is MIT concerned?
As a science-based
university concerned
with the education of
engineers and scientists,
MIT is deeply involved
in industry, and science,
technology, and productivity.
We believe manufacturing
is absolutely
essential to this
nation's economic future.
Technology is the main engine
that drives the economy.
That's the message MIT
economist Robert Solow
has been teaching for 30 years.
The problem of US
productivity has
been studied by economists,
by social scientists,
by engineers, and by scientists.
But up to now, no one has
thrown them all together
in a room to thrash
out this problem,
to study it from
the factory floor
on up in the United States
and Europe and in Japan,
and to see what MIT and other
universities might do about it.
That's why I appointed 16
MIT faculty, from the Schools
of Science, Engineering, from
the Department of Economics,
and from Social Sciences to
this committee in November 1986,
and asked them to
wrestle with this problem
until they came to a shared
perspective, a common view,
about the problem and about
what might be done about it.
I should note that this is
the first such effort we've
undertaken at MIT, at
least since World War II,
and perhaps going back
much earlier than that.
We have with us today professors
Michael Dertouzos, Richard
Lester, Robert Solow, Suzanne
Berger, and Lester Thurow,
six of the 16 commissioners.
Michael Dertouzos, the
Chairman of the Commission,
is Professor of Computer Science
and Electrical Engineering,
and Director of
the MIT Laboratory
for Computer Science.
He's played a major
role in fostering
cooperation between
industry, and universities
in the computer
field, and he's been
a leader in innovative
curriculum development
and computer science.
Made in America-- Regaining
the Productive Edge
reports on the conclusions
of this commission.
What MIT and other
leading universities
should do to contribute to
improving US productivity,
and what industry must do to
get us back in the fast lane.
Now, Professor
Dertouzos will give you
a 20-minute summary of
two years of work, which
involved more than 75 people.
He will then introduce the
other panelists who are here,
and we will try to
respond to your questions.
Michael.
DERTOUZOS: Thank you, Paul.
Good morning, ladies
and gentlemen.
The message that
we are in trouble
is by no means shared today--
nor was it shared when
we started our work
--by the people of this nation.
Some people said then,
as they say today,
that the US is in big trouble.
They say we've lost automobiles,
we've lost textiles,
they say we've lost consumer
electronics, and steel.
They also say that
US products are
becoming expensive and
of lower quality compared
to foreign products.
Our annual trade deficit
is huge, at $120 billion,
and United States productivity
is growing slowly.
But there are others,
especially our leaders,
who tell us that
we're second to none.
And it is true that, while US
productivity is growing slowly,
it is nevertheless the
highest in the world.
Also, unemployment is low, and
our plants are working at close
to full capacity.
So who is right?
Are we in trouble, or are we OK?
As the President
told you, the verdict
of this commission
after two years of work
is that the United States'
industrial performance
is indeed in serious trouble.
And this matters a great
deal, because if we do not
mend our ways, all Americans
will pay the price in terms
of our standard of living.
But to correct this problem,
we must first understand it.
Unfortunately, if
you string together
all the accounts in the press
and all the scholarly studies
that report on this issue
and on the weaknesses
of American industrial
performance,
you get a list so large
that it is unbelievable.
So we set out to separate the
important from the unimportant
in our own way.
We took a different approach
from most other studies
that treat the US economy
like a box with knobs
that you turn to control
exchange rates or interest
rates.
It's not that we do not believe
in macroeconomic factors,
we just don't think they are
adequate to explain or correct
the nation's
productivity problems.
So we based our work
on a bottom-up study
of these eight industries,
which are shown here, along
with the trade balance.
They include winners and
losers, and together they
account for some 28% of
United States' manufacturing.
We split ourselves
into eight groups,
and carried out 550 interviews
in three continents,
concentrating on what
happens at the factory floor,
in the office, and
in the board room.
We also formed a ninth group,
which looked at education,
both at school and at work.
We then took all these
results-- from the eight studies
of the industries and the
ninth group of education
--and we pulled them
together and searched
for common patterns
of weaknesses.
None of the weaknesses
that emerged
from this bottom-up
study will be new to you,
since, as I said earlier,
every conceivable weakness
has been brought forth.
What is new in
the MIT results is
which of the many
reported weaknesses
emerged as actual patterns
from this bottom-up study.
There are only six.
First weakness--
outdated strategies.
In the best US and
foreign companies,
mass production has
given way to short runs
of sophisticated, high-quality,
customized products.
Yet we have found that
the bulk of US companies
still cling to an
inflexible mass production
strategy that worked well
in the days of Henry Ford.
Workers are still
treated like cogs
in a wheel that must be kept
turning no matter what--
the wheel of production.
This older, rigid
system turns out
to be less productive than
the newer, more flexible ones.
So that is one of our
outdated strategies,
clinging to mass production.
But there is a second.
We are also parochial.
We still look to
the United States
as the sole source
of everything,
and particularly of technology.
US companies, for example,
were late in introducing
the basic oxygen furnace or
the Kawabata measuring system
in textiles.
Both were foreign technologies.
We also assume
that others share--
or at least they should
share --our tastes
in the way we do business,
as did one of our companies
that we studied that shipped
a huge quantity of sweatshirts
to Europe, expecting
that they would sell
as well as they were selling at
home, and found out, of course,
that they did not.
But let us move on to
the second weakness--
short time horizons.
Now here is a familiar pattern.
A famous American
electronics company
faces competition at the
low end of its market--
say, the transistor radios,
--from a Japanese company,
or companies.
It abandons that
market to Japan.
It holds on to its higher-end
commercial electronics
products, and then
it turns around
and it buys a rental car
company or a finance company.
Now, they do this
because they believe
that it shows a higher return
on investment, a higher ROI.
Meanwhile, the Japanese
company builds its knowledge
and expertise in
this area, builds up
market share, holding
profits low or zero,
and eventually assaults
the higher-end commercial
electronic products of
the American company.
And so it is that in consumer
electronics, where we once
produced 90% of what we
consumed, we're now down to 4%.
By not sticking
to their knitting,
as we call this
behavior, US companies
end up losing both
expertise and market share.
Now, it is often said that
the high cost of capital
is the culprit that
pushes our companies
toward a short-term orientation.
The commission agrees
that this is a factor,
but we have found
other factors as well.
For example, these ROI
calculations, when in error,
tend to favor the short-term,
and the investing strategies
of fund managers
who control a lot
of the stock of
these companies value
companies with
short-term profits.
Third weakness--
technological weaknesses
in development and production.
The United States is
first in the world
in inventing new products.
Transistors, color television,
VCRs were all invented here,
yet none of these products, or
hardly any of these products,
are made here today.
And the products that we
make, for example automobiles,
have a larger
number of defects--
in the case of cars,
almost two to one
--compared to Japanese products.
It's almost as if we've spent
so much energy inventing
that there is none
left to convert
our inventions into products.
In fact, we do spend 2/3
of our industrial R&D
money on the inventing side,
and 1/3 on the processes
that make products out
of these interventions.
In Japan, this
ratio is a reverse.
Beyond that, our
attitudes, too, favor
intervention over production.
We glorify the
inventor, and we feel
that a career in manufacturing
spells sheer drudgery.
We tend to design
quickly, and debug later,
whereas in the best companies,
both here and abroad,
people build quality
into the design.
We also look for
breakthrough strategies.
We look for that aha that is
going to solve our problems,
and we do not believe so much
in the incremental, steady,
gradual, improvements that are
favored by the world's best
companies.
We even have this word, or
this phrase, in our culture.
We say, if it ain't
broke yet, don't fix it.
Fourth weakness-- neglect
of human resources.
First and foremost, we neglect
education at the kindergarten
through 12th grade level.
The United States, a nation
that pioneered mass education,
is now ranking--
through its high
school students,
worldwide, in various exams
from math and geography
and reading --between
8th and 15th
among the nations of the world.
And this slippage is happening
at a very wrong time, when
the new systems
of production call
for greater technical
literacy in the workforce.
This educational problem
of the United States youth
is perhaps the biggest
weakness that we face.
But there is more.
We also neglect our workforce.
We tend to view labor
as a cost factor
to be minimized rather
than a precious asset
to be nurtured and developed.
Let me explain.
Our vocational schools
are not effective,
and on-the-job training, on
which our companies spend
over $50 or $60 billion
a year, involves
either remedial training,
like reading and arithmetic,
or following Joe around to
learn how things are done.
By contrast, in
Japan and in Germany,
workers undergo
systematic job rotations
that makes them broader, more
flexible, and more willing
to learn new skills.
As a result, when a plant
fails in the United States,
some centralized team
has to be brought over
to correct the damage, and that
takes time and induces delays.
In Japan and Germany, most of
the time, failures of plants
are handled by the
operators, because they've
been trained broadly
enough to understand
all the aspects of their
plant, thereby saving time
and money for their companies.
Fifth weakness--
failures of cooperation.
We found this at several levels.
First, there are
failures of cooperation
within our companies.
Here is a pattern.
The designers design a product,
they toss it over the wall
to the production people.
The production people
try to build it.
It doesn't work very well.
They write some
corrections, toss it back
over the wall for redesign.
This ping pong goes
on and on, and can
be traced to induce delays
in the production process.
In copiers, in automobiles,
and in other products,
we have found these delays
to amount as much as two
to one compared
to companies that
do not follow these practices.
But there are other
failures of cooperation.
There are failures of
cooperation between the company
and its suppliers.
In the US automobile
business, for example,
as in other businesses, we
find in this country thousands
of suppliers.
Whereas, in the
best of companies,
both here and abroad, one
finds hundreds of suppliers--
same business.
Also, there is a
difference in the way
we deal with our suppliers.
In the US, the
relationship is based
on an adversarial thing, the
contract, and the spectre
of potential litigation.
Whereas in the best
companies, the relationship
is one of cooperation and
sharing a mutual goal.
We also found failures
of cooperation
among competing companies.
Now, you would say, why should
competing companies cooperate?
For one thing, to
develop common standards.
In the numerically-controlled
machine tool business,
for example, we have
found that in this country
we had great
difficulty in agreeing
on the language for these
machines to talk to each other.
The Japanese have
no such problem.
They got one company to
construct the controllers,
and they settled
on the language.
Never mind that it
wasn't the best language.
It was common.
And apparently,
we haven't learned
yet, because in the area
of computer networks,
we have exactly the
same problem today.
We have one standard for almost
every company that we have
that makes networks.
Sixth weakness-- government
and industry at cross purposes.
When we started our study,
our friends from business
told us that too
much government was
what was causing their
difficulties, and America's
productivity plight.
Now our industry studies
did not bear this out,
nor did they bear
out the opposite.
What we did find is that
government and industry
are going their own way,
following their own agendas,
oblivious to each other's
needs and aspirations.
Now, if you're becoming
depressed by all this gloom,
let me say that, in
our industry studies,
we were also heartened to
find common patterns of best
practices, those
companies that do
as well or better than
their foreign adversaries
in the international arena.
Since what we found
out is included
in our recommendations
of best practices,
or imperatives if
you wish, I am going
to try to save time and move on.
Now, studying the
weaknesses in America,
as well as the
strengths, isn't enough,
because that takes
us only up to now.
We need to look at the future.
So the commission tried to
identify future trends that
would govern business.
And we came up with
three broad such trends.
We believe that the world will
become even more international
than it is today, and
therefore even smaller.
Second, people will expect
and will get higher-quality,
more sophisticated products.
Third, technology,
and particularly
information technology,
biotechnology,
and material
technology, will become
more critical to the
production of goods.
Now these trends
spell out a quickening
of the pace, the
need for US companies
to be more agile, more
flexible and more sophisticated
if we are to compete
effectively in the world.
Now, the MIT commission
combined what
we learned from studying these
weaknesses, the strengths,
and the future trends.
We put them all together to come
up with our recommendations.
There are five imperatives
that, if followed by industry,
by government, and
by the nation's
educational institutions,
will help America
regain its productive edge.
I will describe them
briefly and broadly.
The book spells
out what they mean
for each of the players,
namely industry, government,
and educational institutions.
First imperative-- focus on
producing well the new way.
What do we mean by that?
For one thing, we mean
that we must stop putting
finance ahead of production.
This business of manipulating
financial instruments
from one mirror to another is
no way to create new wealth.
And we must focus as much
attention on production
processes as we do today on
the inventing of new products.
Our managers, too,
will no longer
be able to remain detached,
saying, as they often do today,
I can do anything.
Point me.
What do you want, paper
clips, or jet aircraft?
I can make it.
Tomorrow's best
managers will need
to know their
product intimately.
Second imperative-- cultivate
a new economic citizenship.
As we have seen, the
old rigid system,
where each individual
worker and each supplier
is a cog in this large
wheel of production,
and if they don't
behave, you toss them
so that the wheel
can keep turning,
that old system of
production works no more.
Employees must now be given
greater breadth, greater
responsibility, and
broader on-the-job training
in order to be productive within
new sophisticated and flexible
systems of production.
And since so much more is
being asked of the workforce,
they must also be rewarded,
both with participation
in the firm's gains, and with
greater employment stability.
But we can go beyond
the utilitarian notions
that we need to treat workers
well so that they will produce
better, which is true.
We can go beyond that.
There is an unprecedented
opportunity here
to give the United
States workforce
a new sense of mastery of their
work environment and greater
job satisfaction.
And that's why we call it
a new economic citizenship.
Third imperative-- blend
cooperation and individualism.
When the stakes
are high, we have
shown that we can do both,
as do the Boston Celtics,
or, more seriously, the best of
companies in the United States.
Now, we can take some
practical steps, too.
We can begin doing
this by flattening
organizational
hierarchies, which
now run 17 layers deep,
from the boss to the lowest
person in the company.
And we can begin rewarding,
with bonuses, both individualism
and cooperation in companies.
Fourth imperative-- learn to
live in the world economy.
We must learn foreign languages,
cultures, and practices
if we are to compete
in the world arena.
And we must shop internationally
for the best technologies,
wherever they may
happen to arise.
We must also establish
national policies
that will help us save
for productive investment
and balance our budget.
Finally, we should
invest in the future
by investing in infrastructure,
both old and new.
Just as an example,
the commission
thinks that we should
begin investing
in a new national
information network that
will be to information
and business
in the 21st century what
the highway system was
to the transportation
of goods and the economy
in this century.
Let me now conclude with
what the commission believes
is an important observation.
These five imperatives
are not a menu.
They are not a menu from
which you can pick and choose.
They work together-- let's
get them in focus here
--they work together like
a well-oiled mechanism
to bring human resources
and technology together
into a highly-productive
overall system.
In fact, this is the main reason
that when we studied the best
practices in the US,
we found that they
didn't diffuse as widely
as we thought they should.
I mean, if these companies
are doing so well,
why aren't their
practices being copied?
We believe that the reason
is that those companies that
are doing so well are
doing most, if not all,
of these things.
As a result, if another
company wants to imitate them,
they must undergo
so many changes--
and so many wrenching
changes --that it's not easy.
And that's why those
practices are not diffusing.
Now, in closing we of the
MIT Commission on Industrial
Productivity believe that
industry, government,
and the educational institutions
of the United States
can indeed pull together to
carry out these imperatives.
This will require a
great deal of effort
and a considerable change of
attitude, but it must be done.
If we want to live well,
we must produce well.
There are no shortcuts.
On behalf of the
commission, thank you.
Now, as you ask questions,
please identify yourselves
and your organization.
And may I ask the panel
to please come up.
We have no floor
microphones, so we will have
to rephrase your questions.
And before we start, let
me introduce our panelists.
You've already met
President Paul Gray.
Next to him is
Professor Robert Solow,
from our Department of
Economics, Nobel Prize winner
in Economics, 1987.
Next to him, Professor
Richard Lester
of our Nuclear
Engineering Department.
Professor Lester was Executive
Director of the commission,
and Professor Solow
was Vice Chair.
On your extreme right
is Professor Les Thurow,
Dean of our Sloan
School of Management.
And, ladies and gentlemen,
we're ready for your questions.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DERTOUZOS: The question
is if we can describe
what would happen to
America, presumably
the standard of
living of America
that I said would go down if
these imperatives are not met.
Who would like to
take this question?
Gentlemen.
THUROW: Let me--
DERTOUZOS: Les.
THUROW: --take a stab at it.
I mean, there are two things.
One is that if your
productivity is growing,
but at a relatively
slow rate, it
means that parts
of your population
are going to have falls in their
absolute standard of living.
And one of the interesting
things at the moment
in the United States--
if you talk about
plugging along,
you look at what's been
happening in the last 10 years
--if you take the group
the Department of Labor
calls non-supervisory production
workers, which are about 2/3
of the American workforce,
that group's real wages, 8%
below its peak in
1972, and is currently
falling at a rate of a
little less than 1% of year.
And that-- and,
you know, so if you
think of the bottom 2/3
of the American workforce,
the answer is that you
should expect a slow decline
in your absolute
standard of living.
The other problem, of course,
is, if the rest of the world
is doing better, you
also get a decline
in your relative
standard of living.
And I suppose a
good example of that
would be Great Britain, where,
in 1900, they had the world's
highest per capita income.
Their income didn't
go down, but now they
have a standard of living
that's about 2/3 that of what
would occur in the most
advanced developed countries,
like Germany, the
United States, or Japan.
And so, they're
two-barreled answers.
Part of the American population
will suffer a decline
in their absolute
standard of living,
and most of the
American population
would suffer a decline in their
relative standard of living.
DERTOUZOS: Next question.
Yes, sir.
BALL: Gerald Ball,
MIT News office.
Was the commission able to
identify any system, nation,
or government that
might well serve
as a model for the
picture you're presenting?
DERTOUZOS: Do we have a
nation or a government
that could act as a model
for what we are saying here?
Professor Solow.
SOLOW: There's a
short answer to that.
I don't think the
commission in any way
believes that we
ought to try to turn
the US into Japan,
or into West Germany,
or anything of the sort.
We have our own ways of
operating, our own culture,
our own normal
patterns of behavior.
We think that some of them
have become un-functional,
are doing us harm
rather than good.
And those can be
changed without altering
the fundamental
character of the society.
We'll still play
baseball in the spring.
hockey in the winter.
And the US will look
very much like the US.
Inside factories and
between corporations,
that's where the
differences occur.
DERTOUZOS: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Apparently,
there is no past solution?
Apparently there is
no past solution?
I am Victor [INAUDIBLE].
I am a writer here.
And my question is a plural one.
I don't think a solution is
going to emerge pretty soon.
It will take time.
[INAUDIBLE]
DERTOUZOS: I'm sorry.
I couldn't hear the question.
Could you hear it?
PANELIST: It had to
do with the schedule.
DERTOUZOS: Somebody rephrase
it from the table, please.
THUROW: I think the question
is that these kind of changes
take time.
And if you're thinking
about, or are we
talking about a series of
changes over the next 10 years,
or the next 20 years,
and how much time
is there to make
these kind of changes?
As I interpreted the
question, that was it.
DERTOUZOS: Gentlemen.
Anyone wants to
take that question?
SOLOW: Well, I
think the answer is
that this is-- we
are not talking
about the sort of change
that happens one Thursday
at 11 o' clock in the morning.
Many of the things
that we've described--
that Mike described,
have already
started to happen in
American industry,
and they will, we hope,
accelerate in the next years.
There's not a cliff
that one falls over.
There's not a catastrophe
hanging out there on the edge
that one runs the
danger of incurring.
Lester pointed out that
the cost of not doing this
is damage to the standard
of living of our children,
and damage to the relative
position of the United States
in the world.
It's not a single catastrophic
event, but a drawn out process.
We start reversing
that tomorrow,
or in fact, we have
already started
reversing that last
year in many industries.
DERTOUZOS: Paul Gray.
GRAY: These imperatives have
different time constants
in terms of change
that might occur.
In some cases, such as changing
the economic partnership,
as it was described,
within the company--
changing the way in
which the workforce is
perceived, managed, used,
change can begin rather quickly.
Another aspect of
that related weakness
which was described
by the commission
hinges on the quality
of pre-college education
in the United States.
The fact that that roughly
20% of adult population
are functionally illiterate,
the fact that in understanding
of simple mathematics
and in science,
we tend to rank towards the
bottom in every comparison
with other
industrialized nations--
it's going to take a
while to change that.
It's going to take some
time to bring about change
in the quality of pre-college
education across the nation,
but it seems to me we need to
be in on it rather quickly.
DERTOUZOS: The book lists
approximately 11 or so,
I think, ways in which
business could undertake
these imperatives-- translate
or interpret these imperatives.
I'm not going to mention
them here, all, just
mention a couple.
For example, flattening the
organizational hierarchies.
That can be done overnight.
Our large companies can
reorganize themselves,
and they do, overnight.
Developing and adopting
new measures of quality.
For example, instead of
measuring the quality only
in terms of profits,
one could adopt
explicitly measuring the
quality of the product,
and keeping track of it.
Integrating the functions
of design, production,
marketing-- this has already
been happening in the best
US companies, the teams in the
Pro Printer Project at IBM,
and in the Ford Taurus project.
So there are many of these
ways of attacking early.
There are others, as
President Gray said,
that will take much
longer, especially
in the area of human resources.
More questions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] You said
that you are paying a decent
product quality, which is
competitive in the world
market, it is necessary to buy--
to look at [INAUDIBLE]
worth buying.
That good for company that
you import [INAUDIBLE]
On the other hand, you have
those huge trade deficits.
How do you [INAUDIBLE]
DERTOUZOS: The
question is, how do we
reconcile the recommendation
that we shop for the best
technology, wherever
it may arise,
with the huge trade deficit
of the United States.
And the answer is directed to
me, so I will try to answer it.
Putting restrictions,
doing protectionism,
is really no way to solve
the problems before us,
because it invites
retaliation, and it
invites all kinds
of complications
that later haunt everybody.
And I think the essence
of your question--
if there's one answer
to your question
--that's protectionist.
That's what I would say about.
So we have no
alternative but to go
for what we've been preaching
throughout the birth
of this country, which
is a free market economy,
and buying the best technologies
wherever they arise.
This is not where
the problem is.
The problem in America is in
converting the great inventions
in which we are number
one in the world
into high-quality products.
And we simply must
learn to do that.
And that is what our
imperatives are directed to.
Next question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],,
Knight Fellow.
How can the government inspire
companies and businesses
to meet-- to follow
these imperatives?
DERTOUZOS: The question
is, how can the government
inspire the businesses to
follow these imperatives?
Who would like to take this?
THUROW: Let me
take a whack at it,
because I don't think that's
a governmental responsibility.
In some sense, that's
the responsibility
of the press and the media.
Because one of the
things you're supposed
to do is bring to the American
public-- or any public
in the world --some view of
what the rest of the world
looks like.
And one of the things
we're talking about here,
in some sense, is that
the rest of the world
has copied some of the good
things in the United States,
like mass public
education, and then they've
upped the intensity
level, and done it
better than we
have traditionally
done it, which means we've
got to up our intensity level,
and kind of leapfrog once again.
And so I think it's a real
question of, in some sense,
are the media telling
the average citizen
in a way in which the average
citizen can understand it,
that his or her
world has changed,
and standard, good-old
American operating procedures
that used to work 30 years
ago won't work today, simply
because the world is different.
And I don't think
it's Mr. Bush that's
going to solve this problem.
AUDIENCE: It's a
related question.
Does the report have any
specific recommendations
in respect of the
use of the mass media
to increase scientific literacy?
DERTOUZOS: Does the book have
any specific recommendation
about how the mass
media could help
increase scientific interaction,
is that what you're asking?
THUROW: Scientific literacy.
DERTOUZOS: Scientific literacy.
Technical literacy.
I see.
Yes.
[CHUCKLING]
It's a long book, so we'd have
to do a little bit of scanning.
One of the things--
look, the problem
is very complex,
and one cannot look at the
answer to your question
as the panacea.
But let me just cite
a couple of things.
The universities
are the demand side.
are the ones who
take the students that come
from the K through 12 level.
And there, we say that we
might increase our standards
and demand a higher preparation
in technical topics.
But that alone, of
course, is not enough.
Something must be done
on the supply side,
on the teacher side, got
to motivate the students,
take into account the
demographic changes,
and the changes in the ratio
of the population that is going
to be here in 10, 15 years.
So a lot more has to be
done on that side as well,
but there is one possibility.
The other possibility that
is discussed in the book
is lengthening the school
year, which in America is now
one of the shortest among the
school years in the world.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to go back
to Dean Thurow's comments
about the media's
responsibility.
I think the imperatives that
were brought forth today
are exciting, but
they're also not new.
It's a story I've
heard before, and I
think other people have heard.
The message has been out
for a couple of years
that America's not number
one anymore in everything.
The changes are happening, but
they're happening awful slow.
What can people do
to speed that up?
And I do think the government
plays a role in that process.
DERTOUZOS: The
question is, I'd like
to come back to the same issue,
that this is not a new message.
These are known things.
And what, really,
should be done?
What should industry,
government do
to really get things going,
because they're so slow.
I would like to ask the
panel to consider the answer
to your question, while I give
you an answer to the statement
that you made, the assertion
you made, that this is not new.
As I said, none of the
weaknesses you heard
is new, because there have
been hundreds of weaknesses
paraded in the press.
But that is very much
like a person suffering
from a large number
of diseases--
and so he's told, because
everybody who comes by
sees him, sees that
he's sick, and he
says, you've got disease x.
The other person says
you got disease y.
By the time they're
done, he hears
that he suffers from
a hundred diseases.
And then a doctor
comes in and measures
the temperature, and the
blood, and all the good things,
and says you have got
only three diseases.
And then the patient
says, oh, go away.
I've heard about these diseases.
These other people
told me about it.
Now, I want to really
contest the statement
that these results are not new.
The results are very new,
because they tell you
which combination of those
things you've been hearing
forever matter as
you study the problem
from the fact from the bottom
up so I think it is new.
And I think, before that, at
least we at the commission
faced this myriad of
recommendations and questions
and diagnosis, and
you really couldn't
find a way through there.
Now, with that as a
basis, perhaps I can--
SOLOW: May I say two
things, Mr. Chairman?
DERTOUZOS: Yes.
SOLOW: First off, I'm
going to reveal my age
and tell you that
I remember when
Rita Hayworth was everybody's
idea of beautiful movie star.
And, in my youth, there
was a joke that we told--
a girl says to her boyfriend,
what does Rita Hayworth
have that I don't have?
And the boyfriend thinks
for a minute and says,
nothing, but she
groups it better.
And our hope is that we
have grouped it better.
But now let me come to
the rest of the question.
Somebody asked earlier,
and Les answered
that question, particularly,
what can the government do
to inspire this sort of change.
And I think that Lester
gave the right answer.
We are not anticipating
inspiration
from the government
in this respect.
Most American corporations
understand the problem
that they face.
And they need not so much
inspiration as a little bit
of guidance and some energy.
I don't think that
Lester meant to suggest
that there is nothing
that public policy can
do to improve, or speed up.
Or facilitate this process.
There's lots of public policy
out there that's needed.
The report does not
spell out proposed pieces
of legislation or regulation
or anything of the sort.
We didn't think that
that was the right task
for a group of MIT faculty.
But one can easily
infer from what
we have written that policies
that stimulate saving
and investment in the American
economy that make it easier
for corporations to
take the long view,
to commit funds for
risky and long-term
technological development
projects-- any such policies,
and we all know what they are,
actually, would be useful.
The federal government
in this country
has long played a role in
supporting and providing
incentives for research
and development activity,
both in universities,
in nonprofit research
organizations, and
in corporations.
It ought to be doing more.
And not only ought
it to be doing more,
but I think it's a fair
inference, from what we've
said, that we would like
to see the government
support of science
and technology
include support
focused at that part
of technological development
that lies somewhat closer
to the commercial production
end, and not simply basic
research, which is where the
government has specialized up
until now.
So I you ought not to think
of in this group as believing
that no public policy could
be useful, or even necessary,
for this.
There's lots.
THUROW: Let me make
an addendum, too.
I think that I was probably
a little unfair in my earlier
answer, because I think we
also need some leadership
from Washington.
And let me give you a
couple of illustrations.
Remember back during the
Vice Presidential debates
in this presidential campaign,
that Vice President Quayle
basically implied that,
if people in Indiana
grew Belgian endive that
was somehow unpatriotic.
Because somebody had claimed
that you would make more money
growing Belgian endive than
you would American corn.
Well, you can think of
Belgian endive, if you like,
as new technology found abroad--
a product which you can
sell for a high price.
And if you can grow
Belgian endive in Indiana
and sell it for a lot more
money per acre than corn,
then you ought to be
growing Belgian endive.
But if you're so myopic
you say, the only thing
that Americans can do
is grow corn, of course
you're, then, in trouble.
And I think what we need is
some leadership at the top that
understands that
we have a problem.
Now, my impression is that I
think our leaders do understand
we have a problem.
But they have
convinced themselves
that in order to
get elected, you
have to pretend that you
don't have a problem.
And I think what that does is
confuse the public horribly,
because you read about all
the problems in the press.
And then, during our
political campaigns,
our leaders all deny that
there are any problems.
And then, if you're
an average person,
I think you end up
just conflicted.
You say, well, maybe
there are some problems,
but somehow these guys
are running the countries,
and they don't think
there are any problems,
or at least that's
what they say.
And so I think one of the things
we have to do at the government
level is put it out
on the table what
we believe about these
problems, as opposed
to saying that the
only thing that
sells to the American public
in an election campaign
is gross rank optimism.
DERTOUZOS: The book
has nine points
which are recommendations
to government.
And they're the translation
of these imperatives.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Why do
you think that the people--
the recipients of the message
is the broad public, and not
the people who are
responsible for the changes
in the corporations,
for the directors.
Wouldn't it be more effective
to bring this message directly
to these responsible people?
DERTOUZOS: The
question is, who ought
to be the recipient of
our message, the public,
or the more responsible people?
I presume you mean corporate
executives, government
officials.
THUROW: I think the answer,
in the United States,
has to be both.
Because we don't quite have
an establishment in the sense
that some other countries
have an establishment that
came kind of, in some sense,
ram things down people's throat.
And so, when you say the
American establishment
or the Japanese
establishment, I think
you're talking about very
different groups of people
and what they can do.
And since we don't have an
establishment in the sense
that Japan has an
establishment, I
think a much broader
group of people
have to be convinced that change
is necessary in the United
States than perhaps
have to be convinced
in some other countries.
And of course, the
other thing that
is true in the United States
that you have to remember that
is not true, for
example, in Europe--
most Americans never
leave the United States.
Nine out of 10 don't
And so they have no experience
with the rest of the world,
and don't see these
things firsthand.
Well, if you're a European, just
when you go on your vacation,
you're going to see
some other countries,
be someplace where somebody
speaks a different language,
where the refrigerators
don't look exactly the same,
those kind of things.
And so I think this problem
of kind of educating Americans
as to what the rest
of the world is like,
and how it forces them to
adjust their procedures
is much harder, simply
because we are so large.
And, you know, there are
five million Americans
who go to Europe every
summer, but they're
the same five
million every year.
DERTOUZOS: We have a couple
of more questions here.
You were first, yes.
AUDIENCE: I think
that some of the--
DERTOUZOS: Could you
identify yourself?
AUDIENCE: My name
is [INAUDIBLE]..
I am a Knight Fellow.
I think that some of those
[INAUDIBLE] production
or head of finance
are really difficult,
and change the
implication of a system.
So I think, after this book
and have those suggestions,
how do you think you
could implement them?
Like [INAUDIBLE]
with leading persons
from the educational
institutions
and industries and government.
Like, to-- to form a leading
group like to put [INAUDIBLE]
And also, here, at
MIT, you are already
thinking about doing
something like that.
DERTOUZOS: OK, the
question is, what's
the best way to
implement-- or how
are we going to implement
--what we preach in this book.
Professor Lester.
LESTER: Well, let me address
the MIT part of the question.
One of the things that
the report points out,
and that Mike
mentioned, is that we
have observed, in a number of
the industries we looked at,
weaknesses that we call
downstream technical
weaknesses-- weaknesses
in product design,
process design, manufacturing.
And, to some extent--
although not entirely
--that set of weaknesses
can be traced to developments--
an evolution in the way we
think, or have thought about,
engineering education at MIT
and at the other leading
research universities
and technical universities.
Within the last couple of
years, as you may have heard,
we have made a
number of attempts
to rethink that to some degree.
And one of the things we've done
is introduce a master's program
joined with Sloan
and Engineering,
directed towards increasing
the production, if you like,
of engineering and
management-oriented people who
know about and will
practice manufacturing.
That's one of the things
that we've tried to do.
But in fact, our report
calls for a broader approach
to some of these
problems within MIT,
in which we would hope that,
right across the Institute,
more attention would
be given, for example,
to real manufacturing
production problems--
also, more attention, as
Les was talking about,
to the international
aspects of this problem.
So we think that there
are a number of things
that we can do at MIT--
and maybe other
research universities
should also be doing
--to make us, at least,
more responsive to
some of these problems.
DERTOUZOS: This, of
course, is what we should
do at home, which comes first.
And we spell out quite a bit of
what MIT and other universities
should do.
Insofar as industry
is concerned,
besides putting
out our book, we're
having a lot of meetings
with the commission
and the CEOs of companies,
groups, the alumni of MIT.
So we're spreading
the word that way.
And, insofar as
government is concerned,
we are having a briefing at the
executive branch next Monday,
and we're having a briefing
in Congress in the afternoon,
and we're testifying before
Senator Kennedy's committee
on Wednesday.
I think we're doing the best we
can, which a university can do,
which is disseminate its
results through the media
and through the written word.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: Do you already have
reactions, from industry,
to your report?
DERTOUZOS: Yes, we do.
We have several reactions.
And perhaps they
are our friends,
but they're running
fairly positive.
In fact, the back of the book
has quite a few endorsements
from industry.
We better wait till this is
out and see the other comments,
as well.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: I'd like a
little more information
about some of your evidence.
Are there some
specific companies,
where you can point
to companies that
are in a similar situation as
each other, but you can say,
this one looks at
profits 10 years
from now instead of next
quarter, and does a better job.
This one treats workers as
an asset instead of a cost,
and has succeeded better.
What are some specific--
DERTOUZOS: The question is to
give some specific examples
of the studies we have done.
I'd like to call in
Professor Lester.
LESTER: Well, I think one of the
most striking comparisons that
emerged from our work came
out of the steel industry,
where we looked at both
integrated steel companies--
large companies that
basically do everything
--but also, we looked
at and spent some time
visiting some of the mini
mill companies, which
have been quite successful,
over the last several years,
in grabbing market share
from the larger companies.
And we did see pretty
striking differences
in many of these dimensions.
One dimension in
particular that I point to
would be the way these
companies handled human resource
questions.
One of the most striking pieces
of evidence in this respect
concerned Chaparral Steel,
which is a small mini mill
company located in Texas.
In order to learn
about what was going
on around the world in
their particular field,
and in order to import the best
practices, both organization
and technical, that company
sent groups of people--
including production workers and
maintenance workers, as well as
white collar people
within the company
--sent them around the world,
gave them travel funds,
said, you go out and
learn what you can
about what our best
competitors are doing,
and come back and
implement them.
That company also, for example,
sent its production workers
out-- people that
worked on the line,
so to speak --to talk
to their customers,
to find out what those customers
thought of their product,
and what they can
do to improve it.
What one saw in this
particular company--
and I think this is an
example that that would apply
in a number of other
industries --what one saw
was a kind of a breaking down
of some traditional functional
areas, functional
activities within a company,
making the company
more open, so to speak,
to the flow of
information from outside.
And this was a fairly
strong contrast
from what we observed in some
of the older, larger steel
companies.
DERTOUZOS: Let me just
give you an extension
so you can see more examples.
The second half of the
book Made in America
is full of various of
these examples in the eight
industries.
And three weeks from now, we
are publishing through the MIT
Press the nine volumes--
there are actually
two volumes, but there
are nine sets of working
papers of the commission, which
include all the detailed
examples --so that you will
have an ample
opportunity to get more
of the bottom-up material that
drove us to our conclusions.
THUROW: Now, see, part of this
is also just kind of a mindset.
Now, this is not a comparison
so much among American firms,
but if you look at the textiles
section of this report,
the conventional wisdom,
kind of, of the United States
is, textiles is a
low-wage industry,
and you can't
compete in textiles
if you're not mainland
China and paying $2 a day.
The problem with
that conception is
that there is a very successful
high-wage textile industry
in a country like Germany.
And it may be true,
in textiles, you
can't do everything
and pay high wages.
But if you very carefully
put it together, in fact,
there's a very viable,
reasonably-large textile
industry that can
be built that is
survivable in a high-wage
industrial country,
as the Germans demonstrate.
And so the question then is,
can you put that kind of thing
together in the United States.
And there doesn't seem to be any
intrinsic reason, because you
can find individual
firms that are starting
to move in that direction.
But the problem is, you have
to do it as a whole industry.
You can't do it on an
individual firm basis.
Because if you've
got one firm that
is very good at making cloth,
that doesn't save the industry.
You've also got to have
other people to put together
the garment part of it, perhaps
the chemical part of it,
and so forth.
And so, you know, it is possible
to do some things that were--
and if you have these blinders
that say, that's impossible,
you just abandoned
an industry that
shouldn't be fully abandoned.
DERTOUZOS: We have just
a couple of minutes left.
So let's see, you
had a question.
AUDIENCE: I just want to follow.
To the extent that some
of these differences
are obvious in companies
that exist or are observable,
and your comment that other
companies see these as
successful, but can't switch.
It's a wrench in it.
They can't survive as
a company, necessarily,
if US Steel tries
to become Chaparral.
Do some of these
changes mean that there
has to be a different
set of companies,
that we're going to have
new companies that are
built on these new principles?
Or can existing companies
make these changes?
DERTOUZOS: The question is, of
course, since these changes,
the imperatives, are so
many and so wrenching,
what does this mean?
How are we going to be
able to diffuse them
in American industry?
THUROW: Well, I suspect
the truthful answer
is there are going to
be some companies that
can't change, and will
effectively go out of business.
But you can find
examples of big companies
that are trying to make
these kind of changes,
and I think some
reasonably successfully.
I suppose one of the examples
that would be common today, you
know, if you think about Ford.
SOLOW: Well, let me give
you an example which
hasn't played itself out
yet, but is, after all,
on the larger scale.
Roughly with this
sort of thing in mind,
although not
precisely, of course,
the details that
are in this book.
When the General
Motors Corporation
decided to build a car that
they wanted to call the Saturn,
they decided to build it
almost as an entirely separate
company--
different place, a sort of
self-contained management,
simply to be almost independent
of the rest of the corporation.
So if even, sort of, the
arch-typical big corporation
like GM can do that, then I
suppose other corporations
can do the same.
THUROW: To the famous
German luxury cars--
the Mercedes-Benz and the BMWs.
And so, you know, it is possible
to recapture these markets.
And you can see examples,
if you look at luxury cars,
where the sales of foreign
luxury cars are down,
you can turn those
things around.
DERTOUZOS: Two more questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Some economic
practices and beliefs
have very deep roots in
the American society,
to the point that they look
more to foreigners like dogma.
For example, integration
of the state and economy.
And the evidence
in other countries
show that there is
a lot of integration
in every [INAUDIBLE].
How could you consolidate
that economic culture
with the [INAUDIBLE] evolution
of the American society,
and [INAUDIBLE] with the
battles in the Congress.
Could you describe a shopping
list for the Congress?
DERTOUZOS: I think the question
has to do with the fact
that there seemed to be some
deeply rooted American--
some cultural aspects
in American society,
and how do we reconcile
this with what we are doing,
and what we advocate that
we should be doing, right.
AUDIENCE: But I am referring
to the economic aspect--
to the economic
theory and beliefs.
DERTOUZOS: Oh, that there
is a different mindset
in this country about
economic beliefs?
Is that what you--
AUDIENCE: Yes, and
the participation
of the state in the--
DERTOUZOS: The involvement
of the state in the economy.
I see.
Well, I don't know.
One of our distinguished
economists?
Professor Lester.
THUROW: I think your statement
is basically right that we like
to pretend that we're
pragmatists, but in some ways
we are very dogmatic.
And when it comes to
the idea that government
can't do anything well, I think
we are extremely dogmatic.
And I think that's
a bit of dogmatism
that we're going
to have to modify.
For example, if you look
at research and development
in every country in the world,
at least half, and usually 2/3
of the funds, one way or
another, come from government.
And government plays
a very important role
because of what economists
know as externalities.
And we're going to have to face
up to some of those realities.
Now obviously, the
trick of any society
being successful
over the long run
is, can you change
your dogmatism.
You may be a crusader
at every point in time,
but you crusade for
different things
as the decades roll along.
And I think that's going to
be the test over the next two
or three years, is, can we
decide which of these dogmas
are really functional
in the 21st century,
and which of these
dogmas, in some sense,
have to be discarded to be
successful in the 21st century.
SOLOW: Actually, no, I
think that part of it
is the easiest part of it.
Government is the sphere
in which the human race has
developed the greatest
capacity to say one thing
and do another.
I think the harder
problem will be
what you might describe as
the culture of industry,
the notion in this country,
for instance, that trade unions
and management
are bitter enemies
and must always
be bitter enemies,
and concessions or
cooperation between them
is a sign to the rank and
file that somebody is being
betrayed-- that sort of thing.
The notion that
industrial operations
have to be simplified, that
the ideal way to produce
a complicated object
is to break it down
into the most elementary bits
so that an uneducated person,
or even a primitive
robot, can do it.
That's the sort of thing I
think will be harder to change.
And it will change,
not overnight,
but in an evolutionary way.
DERTOUZOS: Professor
Lester wanted to comment.
LESTER: Well, I think
Bob said pretty much what
I was going to say.
Those kinds of changes
don't seem, to me at least,
to be changes that
you can legislate.
This is not the kind of thing
the government can pass laws
about.
These are attitudinal
changes, sometimes quite
fundamental changes,
that will have
to take place over a
long period of time,
and involve all segments of
society, not just, or even
primarily, government.
DERTOUZOS: I know you
have a lot more questions,
but we said we would
stop right now.
Let me just close this
briefing by giving you
a point of view
on this question.
Let us not forget that
this nation is a little bit
different than other nations.
It is not homogenous.
It has, in it, people
from every possible land.
And it has proven in the past
that it can adapt to change.
When it comes to
culture, I personally
do not believe that the
cultural differences are
behind what we have seen here.
You see the NUMMI plant where
American workers are doing just
as well as the Japanese
workers, in terms
of the defects of the cars
that come out, and so forth.
So I think that the
five imperatives
list what are the things
that have to be done.
This nation has
enough youthfulness
in it, enough diversity in its
various ethnic and cultural
groups to be able
to cope with it,
and, if we pull together--
government, industry,
and educational
institutions --we
believe that it can be done.
Thank you very much.
No need.